In squiggly careers, we need to
changeour perspective on progression.
The problem with career ladders is
that they only go in one direction,
and you can only take one step at a time.
If progression purely means promotion,
we miss out on so many of the
opportunities thatare all around us.
We need to stop asking
only, "What job comes next?"
and start asking, "Whatcareer
possibilities am I curious about?".
Exploring our career possibilities
increasesour resilience.
It gives us more options,
and you create more connections.
In squigglycareers, there is
room for everybody to succeed.
And no two squiggles are the same.
The ladderhas been holding
us back for far too long.
But it's not easy to change something
that'sbeen around for over 100 years.
What we need now is more
than a radical rethink.
We needa radical redo,
and change comes from action.